[Musica]
è il Giubileo del
1600 e a Roma come accadeva da 300 anni
si commissionavano opere pubbliche nuove
o grandi straordinari che poi sarebbero
stati considerati capolavori in Palazzi
importanti palazzi cardinalizi Ecco in
quell'anno vengono inaugurate queste due
opere in realtà entrambe sono un
frammento di opere più complesse
l'affresco che si trova al centro della
volta della galleria degli amori degli
Dei di Palazzo Farnese opera di Annibale
Carracci che è già una artista
famosissimo che a Bologna ha fondato con
il fratello e il cugino un'accademia e
arriva a Roma forte di una straordinaria
fama e
prestigio lo stesso anno a pochissima
distanza in una chiesa che poi vi farò
vedere nella chiesa di San Luigi De
francesi venne Però anche inaugurata una
nuova cappella funebre la cappella
contarelli in cui lavora Caravaggio che
dipinge alcune tra le quali Questa è Il
martirio di San
Matteo ora le vedete sono due opere
realizzate nello stesso anno nella
stessa città a pochi metri di distanza
Eppure sembrano due opere completamente
diverse opere realizzate da artisti che
potrebbero appartenere a generazioni a
tempi completamente diversi e invece
sono lì e appaiono nello stesso
momento vi porto all'interno di un
viaggio che durerà 13 minuti per capire
quali sono le scelte che hanno condotto
Caravaggio a realizzare un'opera Così
diversa rispetto a quella di animale
Carracci Carracci Qui sta utilizzando la
stessa luce di Raffaello lo stesso
fisico delle figure di Michelangelo a
cui dà più movimento Caravaggio invece
compie una scelta completamente diversa
perché questa è la chiesa la chiesa di
San Luigi dei Francesi una delle chiese
nazionali di Francia Spero che se siete
venuti a Roma l'abbiate vista l'avrete
Sicuramente studiata sui libri perché
anche in quelle poche ore di storia
dell'arte che si frequenta una scuola è
un luogo fondamentale Caravaggio ha è
del nato nel 1571 nel
1599 a 28 anni più o meno credo
e non ha mai realizzato un'opera per una
chiesa ha solo dipinto per alcuni
collezionisti privati
è quasi Sconosciuto al grande pubblico
molto conosciuto e apprezzato
soprattutto per le sue idee abbastanza
anticonvenzionali nel ristretto mondo
potentissimo dei collezionisti cardinali
nobil uomini è un cardinale un talent
scout si chiama Francesco Maria del
Monte all'epoca a capo della fabbrica di
San Pietro a suggerire ai frati di San
Luigi De francesi di scegliere proprio
lui per compiere un'impresa che ben
altri due artisti avevano rifiutato di
realizzare questa cappella doveva
inaugurare in un anno in cui immaginate
a Roma quante cose si stavano
realizzando e gli artisti che erano
stati coinvolti Girolamo muziano il
Cavalier D'Arpino avevano firmato il
contratto ma si erano poi resi conto che
questa cappella in realtà era una
piccola cosa rispetto per esempio a i
mosaici per l'interno della cupola di
San Pietro che Cavalier D'Arpino aveva
per cui Cavalier D'Arpino aveva ricevuto
una committenza e quindi avevano
abbandonato questo cantiere si
avvicinava il Giubileo e alla ricerca
disperate di una soluzione Francesco
Maria del Monte tir fuori dal cappello
il nome di questo artista che era più
noto per le sue risse per le sue diciamo
mosse diciamo un po' scapate che per i
capolavori in più in una chiesa cosa che
lui non aveva mai
fatto Caravaggio raccoglie la sfida a
pochissimi mesi perché il contratto lo
firma a maggio e per il Natale del 99
devono essere pronte queste tele o
meglio queste
opere quando sceglie che cosa
dipingere gli viene in mente quest'opera
Questa è la cappella la conoscete ma ci
ritorneremo dopo quando deve iniziare a
dipingere una delle scene cioè quella
del Martirio di San Matteo che si trova
alla vostra destra gli viene in mente
un'opera quest'opera qui che casualmente
è un'opera di nibale Carracci e si
trovava proprio a Palazzo Farnese sul
soffitto di una stanza Ercole al
bivio il supereroe chiamiamolo così che
deve scegliere
la virtù cioè la figura vestita o invece
il vizio la figura dicinta che è di
spalle e gli viene in mente questa scena
quando deve impostare la prima tela su
cui lui lavora cioè quella del martirio
ora voi però magari Vedendo questa tela
direte Ma dove sta l'ispirazione
da quella immagine che vi ho fatto
vedere prima dove Caravaggio ha guardato
ad Annibale Carracci in questa nel
costruire questa scena Beh non lo potete
vedere da questa immagine Ma lo potete
vedere e scoprire se guardiamo quello
che nel
1951 è stato scoperto nel sottoporre
questa tela per la prima volta nella
storia perché non era mai stato fatto su
nessun quadro prima d'allora Ai raggi x
è stata fatta una a questo quadro ed è
stato scoperto che sotto quell'immagine
ce n'era un'altra ce n'è un'altra che
Caravaggio aveva dipinto quasi
completamente in cui lo notate al centro
c'era un soldato di spalle che aveva le
gambe più o meno nella stessa posa del
del Vizio della scena dipinta da
Carracci e poi il Santo San Matteo si
trovava lì di
fond i carnefici erano sulla sinistra
l'Angelo non veniva dall'alto come sarà
nella scena finale ma veniva dalla
vostra
destra appunto diceva Ma che state
combinando insomma cioè no cos'è tutto
questo trambusto
caravagio aveva impostato questa scena
completamente Però ad un certo punto
capisce che c'è qualcosa che non
funziona Allora abbandona questa tela
capisce che l'angelo che aveva dipinto
pochi anni prima di spalle non funziona
e decide di farla
riposare si dedica Allora aaltra
immagine che si era impegnato a
dipingere all'interno di quella cappella
cioè la vocazione di San Matteo e qui
come vedete fa una scelta molto
particolare Allora Gesù entra in questo
ambiente e indica con la sua mano una
delle persone che sono sedute intorno a
questo tavolo Chiama Matteo pensate che
questa scena è stata Eh dipinta da
Caravaggio ma anche da Molti altri
artisti interpretando semplicemente due
righe del Vangelo di Matteo in cui
Matteo scrive Tra l'altro di sé stesso
che Gesù eh Arriva Chiama Matteo che sta
raccogliendo le tasse per i romani
Matteo si alza e lo segue non sappiamo
esattamente dove non sappiamo chi c'era
Quindi gli artisti hanno sempre avuto
una grande Libertà nell'impostare questa
scena ora dal punto di vista della
costruzione
dell'immagine Caravaggio decide di
portare la nostra attenzione il nostro
sguardo verso uno dei personaggi che vi
dico subito oggi in realtà molti credono
che non sia effettivamente Matteo
effettivamente però se noi guardiamo
dove si dirige la mano di Gesù dove si
dirige la luce e il personaggio che fa
un gesto molto significativo Matteo
potrebbe essere proprio lui che indica
se stesso stai dicendo a
me Ecco tutta la scena punta alla
costruzione di un movimento che
dall'alto a destra
alla vostra destra segue una diagonale
che si dirige verso l'oggetto della
chiamata perché Caravaggio sceglie di
impostare questa scena utilizzando una
diagonale dopo aver dipinto questo scena
Caravaggio torna sul martirio ed è
chiaro che anche qui a questo punto
Caravaggio sceglie di costruire questa
scena sfruttando un movimento
diagonale che è soprattutto impostato
sulla posizione di quel personaggio che
è lì al centro di nuovo citando
sacquegno Caravaggio inserisce delle
figure e dei gesti e dei movimenti che
concentrano la nostra attenzione ma che
in realtà sono fortemente ambigui Che
cosa sta facendo il personaggio al
centro della scena Beh a prima vista
potrebbe sembrare che avendo la spada in
mano stia per finire dare il colpo di
grazia a Matteo che stava celebrando un
battesimo di spalle Come si celebrava
all'epoca guardando l'altare in fondo
stava battezzando queste figure seminude
per immersione colpito alle spalle cade
e infatti dal suo petto esce un rivolo
di sangue qui lo vedete poco ma è molto
visibile Poi dal vero Allora lo sta
finendo lo sta terminando no guardando
con molta attenzione si capisce che in
realtà questo che potrebbe essere un
carnefice in realtà è un altro dei
neofiti che stava per ricevere il
battesimo quindi è vicino a Matteo e lo
sta aiutando sollevando la sua mano per
ricevere la palma del martirio
dall'angelo che è provvidenzialmente
sbucato dal cielo per approvare questo
sacrificio Del
Santo Guardate quel bambino quel
chirichetto che scappa
urlando è fondamentale per capire come
mai Caravaggio sceglie di cambiare
completamente l'impostazione di questa
scena per capirlo bisogna tornare a
guardare questa cappella ora non vi fate
ingannare dal fatto che ci siano le due
pareti no siano appunto divergenti
immaginate le
dritte nessuno ancora oggi può entrare
dentro questa cappella soltanto i
sacerdoti il 21 settembre celebrano
messa nel giorno di San
Matteo nessuno può trovarsi di fronte a
queste tele tutti ancora oggi quando
andiamo a San Luigi dei Francesi le
guardiamo al di là di una balaustra che
c'è alla base di questa immagine
Quindi quello che noi avremmo visto se
Caravaggio avesse inserito quella figura
al centro di spalle sarebbe stato
estremamente
squilibrato Caravaggio ha impostato la
scena inizialmente come se queste tele
fossero visibili nella collezione di un
palazzo di
fronte tornato poi alla cappella si
rende conto che il punto di vista dei
fedeli non sarebbe mai stato frontale ma
diagonale e bambino che scappa sembra
quasi scappare all'interno della chiesa
e quella mano di Gesù che Chiama Matteo
se Idealmente la
prolungasse
noi Caravaggio sta lavorando in un
momento nel quale i pittori soprattutto
più degli scultori sono stati scelti
Dalla Chiesa come il proprio braccio
armato per convertire i fedeli e
portarli a credere ai dogmi e ai
messaggi del Concilio di Trento
Caravaggio è uno strumento della
politica
ecclesiastica della Chiesa di Roma e non
solo dell'epoca ma allo stesso tempo è
un pittore che ha scelto di coinvolgere
direttamente chi guarda le sue tele e lo
capiamo osservando bene la tela di San
Matteo e l'angelo che è centro dove non
c'è Ovviamente un gioco di diagonale
dove non c'è neanche un'azione da
raccontare perché quello è il momento in
cui Matteo semplicemente riceve la
visione di un angelo che gli elenca la
dinastia Gli antenati di Gesù Cristo
Come accade nel Vangelo Ebbene quando
Caravaggio Deve comporre questa scena
Forse ricorderete questa è la seconda
versione del dipinto c'era una versione
che era questa forse rifiutata forse
acquisita da un
collezionista Comunque la vulgata
dell'epoca raccontava del fatto che
questo Matteo che di cui veniva guidata
la mano dall'angelo per scrivere era
stato immaginato da Caravaggio come un
contadino quindi assolutamente blasfemo
per l'epoca Allora Caravaggio accetta di
ridipingere i fedeli guardate lo
sgabello su cui Matteo ha appoggiato il
suo ginocchio lo vedete è in bilico
sta per cadere e dove
cade dentro la
cappella Caravaggio Riduce la distanza
tra l'immagine e noi attraverso un altro
elemento che è assolutamente
anticonvenzionale
nuovo non dovremmo mai vedere questa
immagine illuminata in questo modo
perché queste sono le luci artificiali
che abbiamo messo oggi queste tele di
Caravaggio sono così sono buie sono
impossibili da distinguere quasi anzi
Questa è anche fin troppo illuminata
Caravaggio sfida lo sguardo dei fedeli
ci impone di concentrare l'attenzione
sui volti sulle mani su quelli che sono
gli elementi che spiegano come in realtà
il messaggio che era stato incaricato di
condurre a chiunque attraverso delle
scelte precise che cambieranno da quel
momento la storia
dell'arte diventa un messaggio più forte
che è Forse l'unica cosa che possiamo
veramente imparare da lui è tentare di
imitare fare scelte che nessuno ha
compiuto prima per fare in modo che le
nostre azioni rimangano nella
storia
l